I would love to hear your process for
creating the playlist for Queens of the
Stone Age for Katya and how you sort of
got her emotion within their songs I
then finding the right music in the very
early stage is always very important for
me that I have an access to my own
material and emotional access because
music is all about emotions and and I
was looking for what is the right tone
for this and the DES tone it has to be
something which is melancholic and
aggressive on the same time and I was
like okay that's Queens music so I made
up this list of certain songs through
all their the Queens albums and I gave
the playlist to to Diane it was it was
an instinctive thought you know of songs
and Diane immediately respond to it
very positive you know what I like she
was on I hate the music you know it was
not like that at all
you know it was like she said it felt
right and so I I get in touch with Josh
home and I told him like hey I'm this
filmmaker from Germany and I'm doing
this film it's a bit tiny and it's about
this and that and and he said can you
send me the fella so I sent him the very
rough cut and he immediately liked the
film a lot and and he asked me like does
the score has to be rock I said Josh do
whatever you feel is right and he did
and I think he made the perfect
soundtrack for it absolutely on a film
set is the director always right 98
percent yes what about the other two
percent the other two percent I've I
feel like sometimes an actor has an
instinct and does you know that this
goes against the instinct of the
director and when you propose it it
turns out sometimes the actors right you
know but I would always always first go
with the directors instinct and
and then you can just sort of tune fine
tune may be fought II do you have any
instances where there was a scene and
and Diane suggested one other way and
how it worked I mean are you are you
sort of married to one idea or you very
fluid in terms of how you approach like
a filming day I work for the I I work
very close with my actors and I don't
know any everything you know it's like
and I would say I know I don't have the
impressions 98 percent I think it's less
you know I don't mean as a humble thing
III mean it as it is you know it's like
I I mean for me working on a set is I
like every aspect of it I like the
technical aspect I like the camera I
like the writing I like you know the the
brakes to do the food but what I like
the most on a set to work on is with the
actors that's the thing how everything
started from me you know that's the
that's the thing what interests me the
most you know and here I really had an
exchange you know that I came up with
half an idea and Diane has half an idea
and together we make one idea out of it
which is right there was in the very
last shot of the trial of the film where
this is trekking back and zooming him
shot you know that was like I had the
idea that Diane has to act this
different than what she's doing in the
film you know and because the technical
element of that shot was so difficult I
mean seven eight takes and maybe Diane
was tired of that emotion I don't know I
don't remember but she or she felt like
it doesn't feel right
she said after the 12 or 13 takes can I
suggest something I would like to do it
different I would like to do nothing
I was like yeah go ahead and she made it
and the moment first of all the that was
the best take in case of chemically you
know and it was like a spiritual thing
it was like that was right because
she give the right emotion the camera
filmed it in the right way I believe in
these things you know so I said I saw
her attitude her idea and I used it for
the whole last part of the film you know
what what what she given there yes so I
was it was more than 80 and 98% I tell
you
so even less less sorry less it was less
than 90 percent even under ideal
circumstances everybody has days where
even if they love a project it gets to
be a lot you know different things
happen life happens so what keeps you
going with something with a project even
when it seems like the universe is sort
of against you which tends to happen
even with something that you love what
keeps you going with a project even when
it seems like there's all these things
in your way and you keep you stay with
it yeah tiny little voice in your in
your ear you know it really is there and
you know everybody can say I don't like
the screenplay and I don't think it's
bankable
you know I don't think anybody will see
it I hear these things especially from
this film you know based on that
screenplay I heard that a lot from very
close people around me but but there's
an inner voice you know when when those
people cannot touch this voice then you
know it's right and then you go on
sometimes if they can touch this voice
you know they may be right and you start
to be like yeah um well once you're
committed to a project you know you're
sort of in it there's no way of having a
bad day I you know I think at least the
times when I've been on a film set and I
felt like you know the movies not gonna
be great or or the director is not all
that great or I don't know whatever you
you can feel in that moment it's your
duty to try and elevate it as much as
you can you know I I there's never been
a moment in my life
on the set where I felt like giving up
you always try and it doesn't always
work out we all know that's a risk I'm
not better than others but you have to
try like sometimes even harder because
of it you know
you